after creating a mysterious character
when he launched his latest album
after hours in march 2020 the weekend is
finally shedding some light on what the
meaning behind
it is so there's the weekend at the
american music awards in november
he had that look on stage um when he
accepted his awards
yes uh yeah all right so he looks like
he's had some work done plastic surgery
and he got really banged up or something
who knows
uh but back in april he simply told
variety this this character is having a
really bad night
and you can come with your own
interpretation of
what it is yeah well now in a teaser
first halftime show performance this
sunday
the weekend is looking great the
bandages are gone
so maybe we'll just get to see that
handsome face no more bandages on sunday
he now tells variety the significance of
the entire head bandages is reflective
of the absurd culture
of hollywood celebrity and people
manipulating themselves
for superficial reasons to please and be
validated it's all progression
and we watch the character storyline hit
heightened levels of danger
and absurdity as this tale goes on so
casey did you like this
whole character that he created i
was not a fan of this character that he
created and the reason why
is because for me the weeknd has always
been this incredible
artist but special because there's
something so mysterious
so you know behind the the curtain about
him there's just something about him
that you know his music has always been
at the forefront and it's always been
this kind of dark imaging and
i really just liked what he did at the
beginning of his career now i feel like
he's in a real pop art
space and i respect it because he's an
incredible visual artist
but at the same time this felt very like
almost like lady gaga vibes to me like i
just when
all these little stunts i was kind of
like okay and i knew there was a deeper
meaning because it's the weekend
everything has a deeper meaning with him
um i did think it was very odd that
people were like oh he got work done and
i'm like if you thought that he got work
done and that's why he had these
bandages
then you obviously are not a fan or
don't know him but it was weird because
the story
at first i thought because the first
music video that he did for this album
with the bandages
i thought he had said and it got miss uh
but i thought it was to do with
you know uh drinking and driving or you
know i thought it was a car accident
message
and then it kind of just evolved into
different things but
i love that he said to variety they
asked him you know you're purposely
you know making your face unattractive
to promote your biggest album and he
responded by saying that
he didn't care about being attractive he
compared he he cared about having a
compelling narrative um
and that's really cool but this felt
very
uh i don't know
i always find i i always find it i
always find it interesting when people
do
an art project based on the sort of you
know mutilation
of one's self for
fame or whatever it is and the people
who do it are always good-looking people
you know like it's it's it's sort of you
know there's
it doesn't come across the way that i
think that it's supposed to
uh with somebody like the weekend uh but
i love that he's a 360 artist i love
that he's just all-encompassing
and i love that he's extremely private
and he wasn't showing up on jimmy kimmel
you know with the bandages on his face
and doing interviews and otherwise it
it it could have you know very quickly
veered into the direction of you know a
pro wrestling gimmick
um but i i like artists like this and i
and i think that he's alone
in that lane right now because i do
think that so many other people of his
peers are incredibly superficial
when it comes to how they physically
present themselves and what they used to
sell
and so i did appreciate you know what he
was what he was trying to say
and it sure wasn't i mean it was
interesting everyone was talking about
it right
like i got no problem with it i i love
it when you wake up in the morning and
you are the artist you are
uh you know when you go to bed at night
and i think that the weekend is sort of
alone in that category right now
yeah janet says stunt that's a great
word for it uh colley says the weekend
it's all about playing characters for
his music very david bowie-esque
um raylen said the meaning behind it's
powerful af
i'm a fan of it jason's the weekend is
overrated someone says the weekend needs
to relax
yeah that's just thinking too it felt
very much like lady gaga to me it felt
force for the weekend like it seemed
like
he was trying to get into that realm of
like katy perry and lady gaga
that where people really talk about
their looks because it's always been
about the weekend's music so
what yeah was this him really trying to
get into that realm where people were
really
talking about his appearance like it
just seemed a bit unnecessary to me it
was weird
but yeah like i don't think the weekend
needs to do stuff like that like i don't
think it really translated that well
like people were just confused most of
the time
yeah yeah and it wasn't a reflection of
himself it was a statement about others
and i think that that's what makes him
different
than say lady gaga or you know lady gaga
was always you know
leading leading by example you know with
what she did and that's where
everybody sort of built that emotional
connection to her where if i understand
this correctly the weekend this was
a statement on others which is you know
right not a very pop
it was not a very tough thing to do
right it's over
the weekend you just for me it's like
you know
as a canadian in hollywood
i can relate to the fact that
this town is crazy it is absolutely
absurd people are doing things to their
faces and their bodies
so regularly um the obsession with
perfection
is ridiculous i mean just again this is
a girl
born in ottawa raised in toronto you
know had you know
grew up in georgia all that stuff when i
come here and i see this it's
insane for me to witness and i can see
that the weekend would feel that way i
do agree that i really like the
messaging i just think the weekend is
too
cool to do some of this stuff like i
think he's just like one of the coolest
guys in music
and when he does anything that feels
like this i the message in the music i
love but when it i can see it
in bandages on a red carpet he's too
cool to me just that's my opinion